hey guys Pete here Westworld season 1
episode 9 is complete and it was a lot
of fun we got some answers but before I
get into that I have to put out a
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
this episode and are not caught up to
episode 9 through this first season
you're gonna want to stop watching now
as a reminder I do the scene by scene
breakdown first and then do theory talk
and wrap-up at the end there will be a
timestamp link in the description so if
you want to skip over the scene by scene
and just jump into the thoughts in
theory just click on that link with that
said let's jump into it right from the
beginning and we get the idea this was
gonna be a little bit different episode
Bernard has made pulled in for
Diagnostics and right off the bat we see
that she isn't actually in sleep mode
she's just pretending and when he puts
her in analysis mode he finds out about
all the changes that have been made to
her of course she's not actually in
analysis mode so when he tries to
contact dr. four she takes over she
reveals his true nature once again then
he goes through this process we've seen
already where he sort of melts down like
he did when he found out he was a host
the last time before he killed Teresa as
he gets up to try to regain control we
see may play her trump card like I
mentioned in the trailer breakdown she
actually is able to control Bernard with
voice commands and she freezes all his
motor functions
well he's frozen she gives a nice little
talk and thankfully reveals to us why
she doesn't just take the pad and erase
the memory she says that's what they
would do to us and we're stronger than
them smarter and we don't have to live
this way she then tells him to clear her
and get her back in the park he does as
he's told and then sort of stumbles out
of the room as he's leaving she tells
him if he's gonna go looking for the
truth he should find the whole thing
there's really a couple interesting bits
I want to talk about before we move on
from the scene the first is it kind of
backs up the idea I was talking about in
the last video about Ford creating hosts
as an improvement over human beings he's
not trying to recreate them he's trying
to make them better than we are this
would be a really bad idea overall
except for he doesn't see them as a
threat because he has control over them
he's basically a backdoor way to make
sure nothing bad
happens well not that nothing bad can
happen but nothing that he can't control
will happen but here in this scene we
see the problem with that Maeve's a host
who's figured out a way to take control
the situation as well so Ford's back
door is a vulnerability to his whole
plan falling apart at the Confederate
OHS camp Logan is sort of gloating over
the whole situation now that he has
Dolores and William captive William
tries to explain that there's something
else going on with Dolores that she's
different and then a surprise move he
tries to talk Logan into helping him get
her out of the park
Dolores chimes in to say why would I
even really want to get out she says if
it's so great out there why is everyone
trying to get in there into the park
Logan then gets creepy and foreshadow is
his plan to get Williams snapped out of
this situation he's in and things end
there
Bernard goes looking for answers in
Ford's office and then we see Ford
arrive in cold storage for a talk but
nard explains that he looked at his code
and realized that Arnold actually wrote
the most elegant parts of him he tells
Ford that he wants access to all of his
memories from the beginning so that he
can basically go back and meet his
creator Arnold and when Ford says no
Bernard pulls a Maeve he pulls a gun
from his pocket which Ford promptly
tells them he can't use and then we see
a hacked version of the original
Clementine come into the room he hands
the gun to her and explains the four
that he changed it so that she can only
respond to his voice commands also he
said when they lobotomized her they
didn't get rid of her prime directives
it's kind of interesting that she has
clothes on I don't really get that I
mean in the cold storage unit they don't
wear clothes obviously but I guess maybe
he roped her whenever he was fixing her
up with this back against the wall for
lets him have his memories we see him
remember his son and then talking on the
skype thing to his made-up wife as far
as we can tell and while he's talking to
her it kind of glitches out and turns
into Ford then we see him with Teresa
then we see Teresa dead and we see him
reliving the memory of asking Ford if he
ever had him do anything like that
before at this point he remembers LC and
Ford brings him out of the memory for
tells him that he warned him and that
the memories could cause him some trauma
Bernard isn't really having it and he
tells them a little trauma can be
illuminating it has him send him back in
looking tries to explain that William
will thank him for this later he doesn't
seem to get the message
so Logan decides that he needs to show
him something more so he grabs a knife
which to me looks a lot like the knife
that the man in black carries around
later he grabs it from one of the
soldiers and then plunges it into the
lorises stomach he spreads the wound
open so William can see that there's
mechanical parts inside which confirms
the fact that this is definitely in the
past obviously it was pretty obvious
when angela was in all three of the
timelines or time frames that we've seen
but this is confirmation without a doubt
that this is something that went on in
the past Evan Rachel Wood does an
awesome job acting in this section and
she delivers one of the best lines of
the episode in my opinion she says there
is beauty in this world Arnold made it
that way but people like you keep
spreading over it like a stain after
Logan tells her that this word wasn't
made for her it was made for people like
him she grabs a knife and cuts his face
William tells her to run in that he'll
find her and she's running away she
falls down and we hear this time Ford's
voice say remember and then she gets
back up the wound is gone
and even though she's still wearing the
same clothes not the blue dress I'm
pretty certain that she's in the present
here not back in the William time frame
so that kind of explains where she's
been at in the real time she's been
retracing the steps a lot of people have
said this but we really hadn't seen it
until this point and it's a little
tricky that they didn't put her back in
the blue dress right here but it makes
sense as far as everything in the
continuity of multiple time frames
Hector arm assist and their gang are
having trouble opening the safe he walks
off into the woods to take a piss and
maybe shows up to tell him that she's
going to make him a proposition she
explains that she knows the story and
what's gonna happen and after the Chi
lays out the details of how the gangs
gonna kill each other she steps in
before armistice kills him this builds
trust between them and to totally get
him on her side he she opens the safe
which turns out to be empty the man in
black actually hinted that before if you
remember so I guess he had made it to
this point with Hector before it's
interesting in the scene that Maeve kind
of triggers him by holding a knife to
her stomach again he says we've been in
this situation before and that along
with everything else really seems to
convince him that he should help her do
whatever she wants so
agrees to go to hell with her and they
start to kiss they move into the tent it
looks like it's becoming a cliche bad
boy bad girl kind of love scene and then
we see what Maeve's real purpose is as
Hector asked how they get there she
kicks over the lamp and catches the tent
on fire which means they'll both be
going in for repairs real soon it's a
short scene where Logan tries to make up
with William and it's pretty uneventful
except for that you realize while you're
watching that William is definitely not
on board so whatever Logan's saying is
kind of useless but the gist of it all
is that he's happy that they're gonna be
brothers and William really shouldn't
feel bad because he was just a little
more excited than other people what
happens there stays there he says Angela
wakes Teddy up and then pulls the arrow
that she's stuck in him out she
eventually has him recall what happened
with Wyatt and he realizes that his
memory of the soldiers was actually
wrong in the new memory he sees himself
dressed as a share of shootin all of the
hosts that are in the town he refers to
as escalante the one that we know is
where the hosts were developed before
the actual guests came to the park so
she was there she's able to jog his
memory
and when he says he couldn't have done
it she says yes you did and you will do
it again only this time we'll be
fighting together she goes on to say
that he isn't ready but maybe in the
next life and then she stabs him with
the men in black'''s Knight the man in
black mentions that he's been to the
town that's been buried under the sand
which is where she says they'll fight
and then he says that the maze has
brought him full circle this also
harkens to the idea that he's William
and that's when he went there the first
time but when he mentions the maze she
repeats that it's not for him she then
knocks him out by hang his head on a
rock we see him wake back up next to the
Teddy's body with his knife in him and
we realized that he's got the hangman's
noose around his neck which is attached
to a skittish horse of course this is a
little bit strange because we know the
horse really wouldn't kill him but I
guess we sort of have a suspension of
disbelief at this point and it's a
pretty good scene to watch a play out
after he manages to cut himself loose
though we see Charlotte show up and we
get confirmation that he's part of the
board that's trying to remove Ford she
tells him they need to act and she wants
to move to be a unanimous and he says he
doesn't like to be disturbed when he's
in the park despite the interruption
though he says that he'll she can do
whatever she wants with Ford he's not
gonna block it but don't interrupt him
again he walks off saying he knows where
he has to go now and we assume that he's
going to the white church at the command
center a tech tell Stubbs that they've
got a beacon signal or whatever for LC
she's in the section where the house
with Ford's robot family is he goes up
top to look for and when he gets there
he realizes he can't get in touch with
the command center as this happens the
ghost nation pop up and they won't
freeze when he tells him to stop they
end up bum-rushing him and all we see is
them rolling away on the ground
Logan wakes up from what looks like a
hard night of drinking and discovers
that everyone at the camp has been
slaughtered this is the clip that we saw
from the trailer last week
William explains that he's not in charge
anymore and then he's going to go look
for Dolores
he tells Logan he's gonna help him and
then also tells him not to call him
Billie anymore back in his own memory
Bernard remembers a scene where we see
Maeve laying on the ground while she's
in for repairs that we saw before where
she stabbed herself in the neck with the
scalpel they're discussing what happened
and Ford explains that her cornerstone
memory was overwritten the trauma
induced by seeing her child died was
worse than the original thing that was
her cornerstone I suppose Barnard still
can't wrap his head around this so Ford
adds that creatures can go to extreme
lengths to protect themselves from pain
then we get to see Bernard breakdown
again as he realizes that she was
actually not behaving like a host but
behaving like a conscious being he can't
quite spit the word consciousness out
this Bernard starts to remember the
story that Ford told him about Arnold we
seed the lawyers arrive at the city with
the white church as Ford's talking about
how the malfunctions were pretty
interesting we see her go inside the
church where we see a bunch of hosts
that are basically going nuts as viewers
we realized that she's slipping between
memory and what's really going on
because we see her clothes change as she
walks through the doors from here I'm
just gonna summarize because we get our
reveals and the details aren't as
important because we're gonna go over
this stuff afterwards anyways so she
goes into the confessional booth which
turns out to be an elevator to the lower
love
there we see kind of the flashes that we
saw in the trailer and she starts going
between memories and present time we see
her clothing change we see that it's
abandoned at first and then we see it
when it's active we see the young Ford
which is our first flashback Ford and we
see him go by upset he goes into the
other room and he you can hear him
saying something to Arnold but we don't
see who Arnold is while this is going on
Bernard comes out again and he realizes
this cornerstone is what's keeping him
from seeing the whole history he goes in
one more time and this time when his son
dies he actually stops it and tells him
he has to let him go once he does that
he's able to see his own beginning and
we see our second flashback Ford who's
about 10 years younger than he is right
now we see him introduce himself and we
see that he names Bernard Bernard he
also shows us that photographs and now
Bernard is actually in it so all of us
who thought that photo looked really
often it was likely that Bernard was in
it that turned out to be true when
Bernard comes at back he realizes he's
Arnold and is pretty shocked and the
scenes are cut together so we saw
Delores enter that room where we had the
interviews that we thought were probably
Arnold interviewing Delores and find out
that that was the case she tells him
that she went to look for the maze-like
he said but she's only finding pain and
sorrow and he says that he can't help
her and asks her to remember why he
can't at this we find out that she is
actually the person who killed him and
that he's just a memory from there she
goes back upstairs and we hear someone
come to the door of the church she
thinks that it's William but it's
actually in the present time line so
it's man in black after Bernards latest
revelation he decides that he wants to
pick up with the same work that Arnold
was trying to do he wants to find all
the seni and hosts and rescue them for
mentions they probably won't trust him
because he's been a scourge to them and
says that Bernard is actually really
brilliant at it
he's even taught him a few things which
he in turn used on Bernard himself he
sort of eggs Bernard on some more and
then Bernard actually tells Clementine
to shoot him she doesn't follow through
and he realizes that Ford's put a
backdoor in her coat Bernard has this -
so if Hort tells him that he's going to
kind of have him kill himself basically
as he walks out of the room as he walks
away we see the flash in the background
and we see him fall to the ground and
jothee episode ends so this was really
an action-packed episode and there was a
revelation right before Bernard put the
gun up to his head but to shoot when
he's talking about people and the things
that humanity's done he's kind of
echoing his own self as you know he says
like this is you know we ran out of
things to dominate so we made a place
like this he's kind of talking about
himself when he says that right I mean
sure people come there to enjoy his
stories but he's the one who's actually
pulling the strings and he's the one
who's doing the real sort of creepy
without a lack of a better word to use
stuff like the power stuff you know I
think what actually drives this home is
the idea that he has this backdoor but
nard actually wrote the backdoor but he
has this backdoor that he can he can
exploit and Bernard realizes right
before it happens
hey you could have stopped that at any
time you could have actually stopped me
from becoming self-aware on this level
and what Ford was actually doing but
what he said he was doing was that he
was trying to give him the freewill to
see if he would choose to be his partner
again of course he did not he had
Clementine shoot him and you can realize
that this is probably the scenario
that's played out over and over again as
he walks out of the room he says you
should never trust us we're only human
so Bernard is in the image of Arnold the
man in black is 99.5% William I mean the
only thing that's really making it hard
to say okay for sure is that mole that
Jimmy Simpson has maybe next episode
we'll see that come off somewhere but no
really I mean there's there's been a
progression of the layers coming off of
these things and so we knew that there
were more than one timeframe I mean most
of us knew that it was the most likely
outcome for awhile but you know we were
getting these layers of things being
confirmed as time goes on so here we're
pretty much all the way there we just
haven't seen how it came together yet
that was the one thing I was still a
little bit skeptical about but unless
they're totally misdirecting us for a
different kind of twist they're not
being very subtle in the way that
they're hinting at it at this point we
also found out that the Loras killed
Arnold at least in her own memories
that's what happened which is something
that people have said but it's pretty
hard to trust any of the host memories
now that we know what Ford is actually
up to so we're probably going to have to
for a little bit longer to get the whole
idea about that one we got confirmation
that the man in black is involved with
Delos on the board that he actually did
save them financially but we don't
really know how that all went down I
find that interesting that he's not in
defensive Ford at all and that you know
he even says I'm not here for his
stories I'm here for something else
which we know are Arnold stories which
makes you wonder as he gets to the end
of that what happens at that point he's
actively engaged in trying to get the
information out of the park so they can
capitalize on it in other areas so what
does he do with himself if that
backstory he gave us was the real deal
in the last episode there were answers
and then there were questions we found
out that Bernard was built in Arnold's
image but I don't think that's complete
confirmation in any way that Arnold was
a human being well this episode made the
connection between the two it didn't
give us confirmation as to why Arnold is
such a mystery I know Ford could have
scrubbed him from the history of as the
legend suggests but did he do it just so
he could bring him back as a host was
the original Arnold a host to that Ford
built to assist him in building the park
or was he a really bright human being
with a troubled past that eventually got
in the way the Arnold Webber anagram
idea never seemed that solid to me since
the last name was made up and seemed
like a misspelling like it's kind of
like Weber instead of Weber but the idea
of the Alpha and Beta Arnold and Bernard
kind of started to click with me a
little bit while I was watching this
episode does that mean that there will
be a gamma or a seed name next I mean
that isn't clear because in software
development beta is a testing phase so
there isn't a name beyond that have you
ever used a gamma version of anything
probably not I guess the beta phase goes
until the product is ready for release
or it gets shut down so it might just be
a detail that's random or a red herring
but it might give us something to think
about when it comes to the future of
Ford's assistant because I mean he is
shot he's dead right now but there's
certainly nothing to say that he can't
be brought back in the same way Maeve
was I mean he said it yeah we need to
separate her from her corner stone which
was overwritten she didn't go back to
thinking about that until the Loris gave
her the phrase in her ear outside the
mariposa which brings up a whole nother
idea here that we basically have two
different things going on we have four
to make a perfect partner he tells
Bernard that directly he's playing the
god game on a totally different level
he's not trying to recreate
consciousness or recreate humanity
itself he's trying to outdo it on the
other hand we have remnants of Arnold
inside this coat Ford knows it's there
and for some reason he wanted it to come
out so the oil is likely dead but I
guess there's still an outside chance he
might be hidden somewhere but either way
it appears that his goal whether he was
human or not was to live on through the
code thereby extending consciousness
rather than just achieving consciousness
he can't help Dolores when she asks but
he still exists I mean he could still be
accessed so in some ways they're the
opposite sides of the same thing that
Dallas wants to do but just in a
monetized way where they can sell that
to other people and this kind of is a
callback to what may have said about how
there's two different voices arguing
each other in the code so one more thing
about William he does seem to be reborn
in the scene where he kills everyone
there I mean he says that you kept
telling me this was a game and now I
learned how to play it
he realized that he's basically immortal
or a god inside that place he can kill
all those people and they can't really
do anything about it the man in black on
the other hand he says he's not
interested in the narrative he's
interested in this Arnold idea but at
the same time he really is playing a
game I feel like that's more clear now
than it has been in the past you know
there was a lot of things saying well it
can't be William and the man in black
being the same person because the man in
black is so hardened and whatever I
think now that we have confirmation that
he is Della's those hosts are actually
his property and because he's really
been coming back for thirty years and he
hasn't been able to get the Loras to
come back to what she was like the first
time or even remember him then he really
wouldn't see that any problem with just
doing whatever he can to try to advance
in the game I just don't think that
there's any kind of real connection to
him being an evil person if his wife
killed herself because of something that
happened it's something that happened at
the period of time where we see William
at now at the time when the man in black
started going to the park ended up
bailing out the park and then eventually
like Charlotte said becoming addicted to
going there over and over again
even though I didn't like this theory
and the first place said I think it's a
pretty solid connection to those two
characters I mean they don't look
anything alike and like I said there's
that mole involved but I guess we just
have to put faith in whatever comes out
its gonna make sense in the end there
are a couple loose ends the stubs thing
is kind of confusing do we really care
about stubs I guess we're gonna need to
in the next episode I'm pretty sure
that'll get wrapped up I'm not sure
exactly what's going on there for a long
while I was thinking Stubbs was probably
a host but if that's the case why does
he have to abduct him in that way the
other loose end is Elsie I'm still not
exactly buying that she's dead
I mean they're basically serving that to
us on a silver platter that Bernard
killed her but they haven't shown her
dead in any way there's really no
evidence and what we saw tonight so
we're just gonna have to wait till next
week to find out
and then there's Maeve I mentioned in my
last video that I thought made was
setting herself up to be the big
adversary for dr. Ford and I think
that's really playing itself out I'm not
sure if she's gonna get out of there
I mean I'm gonna talk about that a lot
more in the trailer breakdown because we
saw some stuff but it looks like her
plans going off pretty well so far one
thing that's for sure it's gonna be
really exciting to see what happens when
she gets downstairs and puts everything
into action so I'll leave it at that
lets there's a lot more to talk about
let's do that in the comments though if
you liked the video please leave a like
please subscribe to get ready for I'm
actually working on the episode 10
trailer breakdown right after this so
you'll want to be subscribed so you'll
see that when it comes out plus you'll
want to come back next week and see
number 10 so let me know what you're
thinking about all this stuff in the
comments and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
[Music]